natürlich nicht vollumfänglich zufrieden
stellen das ist doch klar aber trotzdem
gibt es an diesem wahlabend auch einige
punkte über die wir uns zu recht freuen
können und auf die wir auch stolz sein
können wir können stolz darauf sein dass
unsere kampagne in bayern mobilisiert
hat die wahlbeteiligung in bayern sogar
deutlich höher als in anderen teilen des
landes die wahlbeteiligung in bayern hat
gezeigt die menschen waren mobilisiert
sie sind zur wahl gegangen sie haben ihr
demokratisches recht wahr gemacht und
wir haben einen ganz wichtigen beitrag
mit ihrer stimmabgabe geleistet sie
haben erstens zu einem signifikanten
guten unions ergebnis deutschlandweit
beigetragen das glaube ich kann man auch
jetzt schon sagen und meine damen und
herren liebe freunde sie haben mit ihrer
stimmabgabe ein linksbündnis verhindert
das war eines der zentralen ziele
herzliches dankeschön für diesen einsatz
[Applaus]
ich sage ich sage stellvertretend seinen
parteilosen dankeschön dankeschön für
dieses ergebnis der gemeinsamen arbeit
der partner arbeit aber wir wollen auch
unsere partei versuchte markus söder
danke sagen dass wir als csu auch in
bayern bei diesen schwierigen
randbedingungen zu dastehen und dieses
ergebnis errungen haben hat ganz im
wesentlichen auch mit markus söder zu
tun auch unseren parteivorsitzenden
herzliches dankeschön für einen kleinen
einsatz gewesen war